attention le reportage qui suit contient
une bonne quantité de matière grasse
nous préférons vous en avertir la
gastronomie c'est l'art de la bonne
chère depuis quelques années des chefs
comme martin juneau met en valeur le
flanc port une partie qui n'a pas
toujours été prise et on a le porcelet
parce que si c'est le fla moi j'aime
bien l'appeler la poitrine plus pour
coiffer l'ens poitrine
ben moi je trouve que la poitrine c'est
plus sexy serait maintenue et que les
éleveurs eux-mêmes vous redire du plan
par le flot en fait j'ai situé sur la
partie du ventre de l'animal facto cette
partie qui va être ici dans le fond qui
va être la partie inférieure de l'animal
il ya un retour vers le port parce qu'il
ya des éleveurs au québec qui font du
bon port puis aussi qui va être plus
goûteux qui va être plus gras parce que
les gens vont réapprendre à manger le
grave également aussi tu vas donner du
goût à l'avion
[Musique]
notre relation avec le caution ne date
pas d'hier
lamonde % des québécois ça remonte
vraiment autant des français c'est très
ancien à l'époque de jacques cartier
troisième voyage en 15 41
il vient ici il apporte avec lui des
cochons et c'est vraiment au siècle
suivant donc après l'arrivée de samuel
de champlain qu'on va commencer à élever
des cochons en nouvelle france et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que aujourd'hui
quand on élève des cochons c'est parce
qu'on veut la viande de porc mais à
l'époque l'unique chose pratiquement qui
nous intéressait c'était le lard et ont
qualifié un éleveur de bon en fonction
de l'épaisseur du lard de son cochon et
plus été grand plus on aimait ça à
l'époque de la nouvelle france une
famille moyenne par année consommer 40
kg de lard
com
c'est avec le lard salé que les
populations autochtones découvre alors
le sait les coureurs des bois quand il
partait sayf dans leur exploration il
apportait avec eux du lard premièrement
parce que ça se conservait mais aussi
parce que c'est très calorifique
on avait besoin d'énergie on faisait du
portage et s'est envolé sur nos millimes
majeures de l'art c'est une partie qui
est peu connue je trouve peu utilisé par
les gens parce que toujours on a
toujours ce petit truc que les gens ne
veulent pas trop de gras et c'est une
partie qui est grasse mais après de plus
en plus on m'en demande quand même des
clients qui veulent essayer puis après
une fois qu'ils ont essayé ils trouvent
que c'est magique parce que c'est c'est
super gouttes
[Musique]
bien présent dans la cuisine est aussi
dans les livres de recettes d'antan
l'oeuf l'import apportait saveurs et
matières grasses à différents plats
comme les fèves au lard
on entrait longtemps on s'est dit que
c'était les américains qui avaient
apporté les fèves au lard au 19e siècle
attention et fèves au lard ça existe
depuis le 14e siècle en france et les
français ici vont aussi faire des five o
là la seule chance et qu'on mettait un
bol de sirop d'érable ou de mélasse à
côté et si on voulait en rajouter un peu
de sucre alors que les américains eux
l'imbiber de sucre
de nos jours 75% des flancs sur le
marché sont transformés en véhicules
autre façon de vendre ses flancs sous
forme de blocs salé et fumée qu'on
taille en art dont le lardons en cuisine
ça sert à quoi
mais dollars dont 500 lapins deux choses
premièrement à être bon c'est le lard
danse et croustillant ces fumées
moi j'aime bien quand l'extérieur
croustillantes l'intérêt moi le moi je
trouve que c'est un bel accompagnement
vance à la salade césar évidemment oui
ça pour être même une garniture pour une
viande volaille par exemple chose a
super bien
[Applaudissements]
notre bouche et un bien préparé une
porte et à partir de son flanc pas une
fois assaisonnez de sel poivre ail et
quelques herbes la viande sera cuite
pendant quelques heures
ce travail de plusieurs façons mais
c'est toujours le même type de cuisson
donc une cuisson lente auprès pas se le
faire sur le barbecue ou à la parole
comme un style qu'il faudra que ce soit
braisé ou confits nous on le fait ici
confidences et du grade parc on utilise
les gens vont dire oh my god tellement
gros comme pièce où ça peut être grand
effectivement mais une fois cuit ce
qu'on fait on a fait trois heures un peu
puis on enlève les parties les plus
grasses mais on essaie d'en garder un
peu quand même parce que le gras égale
goût en quand même le plat signature de
martin juneau
c'est la poitrine de porcelets lakehal
et raf
voilà ça c'est le plat classique du
pastaga il est là depuis juin
des fois on va régler les garnitures de
lorsque si la poitrine elle est là qu au
sirop d'érable avec un banquet et de
carottes puis de marina de cloud et
qu'on a tous on a le sucré l'acide le
gras
je comprends pourquoi t'es pas capable
dans votre cyril plats du menu
[Musique]